ciao a tutti ciao ciao a tutti e otto
ciao a tutti ora questa breve intro
porta dritto dritto al nocciolo della
questione ciao a tutti ciao a tutti e
tratta tutti erano secoli che non
mettevo video ciao a tutti ciao a tutti
ciao a tutti ciao a tutti nota tutte a
tutti a tutti già tutti ciao a tutti
tutti tutti tutti e bentornati nel
canale di whale wars
ciao a tutti ciao a tutti di certo che
c'è un tracciato ciao a tutti sarò
sincera questo qui il video più
terrorizzante che abbia mai fatto
mi fa una paura assurda farlo e sto
cercando di farlo da non so quanto
parliamo delle basi
mi chiamo oscilla io ho caricato il mio
primo video su youtube il 30 dicembre
e l'ultimo il
31 ottobre 2013
vedendo due anni che non faccio video so
che sembro uno degli alcolisti anonimi
proprio ad alcol in questo caso non fare
video è stata una cosa la vedo
personalmente come una cosa negativa
quindi è da due anni che devo e
sicuramente qualcuno di voi se ne era
accorto perché lo scriveva te mentre
stavano finendo diciamo come che sta
finendo il 2013 mi arrivano delle
commenti come dicevamo al numero sempre
lo stesso ma che c'hai ma che ti è
successo e io cercavo di non di non
vederli perché i commenti più delle
volte ragazzi sono come dei grilli
parlanti cioè le persone che ti vogliono
bene ci vedono molto più a lungo di te
vado ad ucciderlo specchio motivi di per
quello che sei adesso da fuori di vero
per quello che sei siti vogliono bene
di che implica anche di mandarti a
pregare e non aiutava non aiuta perché
io a quel punto certo punto ho smesso
fatto di fare video e ha smesso anche se
non sbaglio di postare su twitter ho
cominciato proprio ad abbandonare i
social se avessi potuto se fosse
esistita possibilità verdure cancellato
il mio account on me stesso e appena
avremo internet
c'era il money fine fatto che
nell'ambiente era un pochino mi manchi
ma dai su torna non fare scherzi dopo un
anno era cavolo ma che si è fatto perché
è successo con oltre video torno fra i
video
ed è una costante quella lite ritorno ai
video torna a fare video era come se non
riuscissi a evitare questo l'ostacolo
cercherò di mettere una foto cerca di
costa punto it ma comunque c'era sempre
quel che insieme alla sommità jones lo
re giorgio
ed è difficile perché la cosa più che
più mi piace a matera quando le persone
quando voi anzi alcuni di voi mi
scriveva cavolo ma così ci manchi di
rispetto almeno la decenza di postare un
video almeno farci sapere che sta
succedendo e io ragazzi devo subito
mentre però che i puntini sulle i io ho
mai mai mai
avrei voluto mancarmi di rispetto non
posso anche rispetto a delle persone che
mi hanno aiutato a coronare dei sogni
quando mi dicono vai ma tu sei un grande
perché non sei andato avanti senza
calcinculo io ho sempre detto no io ho
avuto non mi ricordo quanto sono le
chiuse
allora io dicevo tipo 40 milioni di
calcio in culo piccoli perché sono di
persone che per la società magari non
sono vere more compagni è bella ma che
insieme hanno spaccato le chiappe cosa è
successo perché non finire perché non
fai meglio in cui lo spieghi spiega
cielo almeno eccolo ecco questo e dire
questo è tutto
io ho sempre fatto video perché mi
andavo via scendeva la telecamera
quando mi sentivo di voler dire qualcosa
che non va per forza essere bella che
non deve essere per forza fisica che non
doveva per forza peccare di presunzione
sedimenti mentale mi divertiva a fare i
video il motivo per cui non ha insegnato
il motivo per cui 8 stato il primo video
youtube
sei anni fa quasi sette anni fa iniziava
non era un posto figo non era un posto
dove dove le persone
pensavano ma o cioè questo è un grande
fine è 1 youtube e cioè di sammy settimo
un emerito pirla un cretino un cretino è
il rischiatutto solamente nella versione
di farlo cosa è successo a un certo
punto questa passione
è come se fosse stata l'improvvisa
risucchiata banalmente non avevo niente
da dire a me definire a bocca come pesci
rossi che stanno sott'acqua e non dicono
niente non mi andava e come in una
separazione in una separazione fra
atterrato ragazza
dove io sono i ragazzi più bella ragazza
se volete i ragazzi sono ragazze ci sono
andati in mezzo agli amici che siete
siete voi in questi denaro mi sono
successe di cose cercherò di andare
veloce cosa ho fatto e mi sono
trasferito a milano
nel frattempo ho scritto un libro ovvero
pubblicato l'inganno della morte che
erano struggle scritto da quando avevo
16 anni sono andato sono andato a los
angeles recentemente sono molto
divertente anche se troppo grande in
realtà è un po caotica los angeles
ritratto però ho fatto un film in
inglese palermo che ho fatto una serie
fatto una serie per raiuno molto
realtà ma grande opportunità è stata e
che accordo uscire cos'altro fatto sono
andato a londra ho una macchina o un
cane ragazzi io da due anni un cane e
non sta qui con me perché perché non c'è
sta con mia madre
e questo no ragazzi è la cosa più
importante che un cane da due anni ed è
bellissimo perché sono andato via da
solo
questa è casa mia magari un giorno
faccio vedere meglio presa qui è la mia
zona stucchevole mia libreria tra
parentesi
speravo che nessuno vedesse ma questi il
cofanetto di twilight
quindi all'inizio stavo tipo ciao
ragazzi come state non volevo
assolutamente che che lo vedeste ho
imparato a fare il sushi
ho imparato cucivo imparato un sacco di
cose ragazzi ci sono diventato una
massaia ho imparato a fare veramente
bene il bucato ragazzi e pulisco
benissimo la cucina il bagno mi affido
con la radio ha smesso da quest'anno ho
lasciato milano il suo tornato a roma
perché non stavo bene a roma e del
momento in questo torno barone realtà
poi è cominciato a mente molto meno in
ordine la mia vita c'è voluto un anno e
mezzo per metterla definitivamente in
ordine e voi siete l'ultima l'ultima
cosa che io metto in ordine che siete
qual è l'ultimo se si mette in ordine in
un armadio e le cose che indossi più
spesso sono le ultime cose che 20
l'ordine non sono quelle che bevi
ti parlo solo i vecchi ricordi sono
quelli che della giornata sulle mutande
che le porti sempre con te comunque non
posso continuare a parlare troppo perché
sono questo video diventerà terribile
cioè terribilmente lungo e non mi va di
ammorbarvi non volevo e spero di essere
riuscito a dire tutto quello che pensavo
mettete sempre avanti il vostro cuore
voglio finire con la fresca seria no
l'ho pensata carina guardate è l'unica
cosa che veramente capito in questo
periodo e mettete avanti cuore
allego a volte l'orgoglio e quant'altro
ti fregano
la paura ti frega ti frega tantissimo
alle volte è meglio essere non aver
paura di essere fragili che aver paura
di essere forti quindi ho sempre fatto
arriviamo qui niente sono stati anni
difficili questi qui sono stati i miei
due anni io spero di potervi continuare
a raccontare quali sono stati i due anni
perché in realtà ho fatto un sacco di
cose ma adesso mentre non ha raccontate
così non mi venivano e niente si si
ricomincia da adesso
e voi che ci avete fatto in questi due
anni